eine absolute Tragödie in Frankfurt hier
ist heute morgen ein 13-Jähriger unter
eine Straßenbahn geraten und wird dabei
tödlich verletzt der Junge wollte wohl
noch schnell über die Gleise im Bereich
der Haltestelle die an rollende
Straßenbahn konnte dann aber nicht mehr
rechtzeitig bremsen erfasst den Jungen
der Gerät unter die Tram wird
eingeklemmt und stirbt noch an der
Unfallstelle vor Ort ist jetzt unsere
weltreporterin Jessica vierlei dort an
der Unfallstelle Jessica was genau hat
sich dort heute morgen abgespielt
[Musik]
das müssen tragödische tragödische
entschuldigung es müssen tragisches Ding
gewesen sein wenn man sich das mal hier
vorstellt mir geht mir auch ziemlich
ziemlich nahe ich habe selbst den
kleinen Bruder der ist 13 deswegen muss
mich schon ein bisschen zusammenreißen
das sind jetzt zwar noch nicht irgendwie
Blumen oder Kerzen ausgelegt wurden
wurden es war da vorher noch ein paar
Ermittler vor Ort die dann natürlich
hier geschaut haben Fotos gemacht haben
von der Stelle wo das passiert sein soll
auch sie wissen noch nicht genau wie es
passiert ist ob er sich beeilt hat und
noch schnell zu traben wollte weil er zu
spät für die Schule war das ist jetzt
alles noch Gegenstand der Ermittlungen
man weiß nur dass es 7:40 Uhr war als
der Junge auf dem Schulweg von der
Straßenbahn hier erfasst wurde
die Ermittlungen zur Unfallursache
dauern noch an auch die Schuldfrage muss
wohl noch geklärt werden wir haben
gerade noch gehört dass der Junge wohl
die Fußgängerampel genutzt haben sollte
was weißt du darüber
auch noch nicht viel das ist halt jetzt
die Frage und noch Gegenstand der
Ermittlungen das wird jetzt
herausgefunden ob die Ampel grün war und
er einfach ganz normal über die Gleise
gelaufen ist ob das die Schuld des
Lokführers war oder ob der Junge nicht
richtig geguckt hat
tragisches zu Unglück dort der Tote
eines 13-jährigen der von einer Trambahn
erfasst wurde Jessica feelight vielen
herzlichen Dank für deine information
[Musik]